it seems like Nvidia was so close this
time they almost had a reasonable RTX 50
Series GPU welcome to my video on the
RTX 570 TI once again I'm making an
alternative launch Day video with some
slightly different content than usual if
you want to know why you might have seen
my video earlier today where I talked
about this only arriving within the last
24 hours which is not enough time to do
a full review but since a lot of you
guys enjoyed my RTX 55090 review Roundup
as well as my RTX 580 generational
uplift video I thought for the 70 TI
foros excellent today's video is brought
to you by the Paul's Hardware store on
Pauls hardware. net the only official
source for Paul's Hardware merchandise
tantalizing t-shirts brilliant beer sets
high quality hoodies and more all
featuring The Classic thumb screw for
tasteful and refined viewers or the 8bit
thumb screw for tasteful and refined
viewers who hate curves new designs are
added sporadically and at random so head
over to Pauls hardware. net and get some
of that sweet sweet merch right now or
not right now after you watch the video
either way so one thing that I do really
like about launch days still despite so
many of the things that I used to like
about them not being things anymore
thanks to pricing being out of control
and a general lack of enthusiasm as a
result of those really crazy prices but
I do still like how when a new GPU
launches there's going to be a bunch of
reviews that go up and you can check out
a wide variety of them in order to get
sort of a broad assessment of the new
product from a bunch of different
sources and the reviews that I've
selected today are all from sources that
I trust we have Hardware unboxed Gamers
Nexus Optimum Linus Tech tips derau and
js2 cents and all of their videos are
linked in the description if you haven't
watched them yet I recommend checking
them out if you want a lot more detail
than what I'm going to go over today but
the to Long didn't watch summary is if
the 570 TI was actually its base MSRP
price of $750 as promised it would be a
reasonable price to Performance offering
given current pricing and availability
because there are no other cards to even
buy in this price range right now
especially if you're in the US they're
all sold out now those are already some
pretty serious caveats because if there
are no other alternative gpus to buy
then we are simply at the mercy of
Nvidia add and board partners and
retailers to sell these cards for a
reasonable price but we all already know
that that's just not going to happen
when demand is high and Supply is low
the people who are in charge of the
supply are going to try to make as much
profit as possible in that situation and
hence while there are a handful of
supposedly MSRP RTX 570 TI like this
Asus Prime model which is not
overclocked but the assumption that I
and many others are making is that these
MSRP cards are going to be extremely
scarce and chances are what you'll
actually see available at retail if any
are available at all will be the cards
that cost $900 plus part of the reason
for that is that while we have seen a
few listings at 750 bucks for these
cards there's a big gap between those
and the next tier up those all just seem
to start at $900 which is a very big
jump from the base price but as long as
you are aware that that $750 promise is
probably going to be broken we can
proceed and talk about other things like
the actual performance of the card which
is not horrible and that's not
necessarily A ringing endorsement but it
kind of is given the current state of
Nvidia GPU launches lately espe espe
with the RTX 50 Series the 5070 TI
performs about the same as a 4080 or
4080 super those cards cost $11,000 so
does that mean $1,000 is reasonable for
the 5070 TI well Nvidia seems to think
so and probably the scalpers out there
are going to be thinking so as well as
I'm not going to be too surprised if we
see these jump up well above $11,000 at
least in the few days after launch or
until Invidia can get more units onto
store shelves and we don't know how long
that's going to take still Nvidia was on
the verge of the reviews for the 570 TI
not being terrible but unfortunately the
generational performance uplift as we'll
look at in just a moment is pretty
stagnant once again given that the 5070
TI is typically a few frames behind 4080
or 480 super so all of the reviews are
pretty much saying the same thing do not
buy this GPU particularly if it costs
$1,000 plus but as a follow-up
prediction I will say once again none of
the reviewer's advice is going to matter
because these are going to sell out
anyway okay let's take a look at some
more specific specific data from the
revieww Roundup the overall conclusion
is that the RTX 5070 TI when compared to
last generation and you might be
comparing it to the 407 TI or the 4070
TI super is that you're going to see
about a 7 to 20% raw performance boost
over the RTX 470 TI super or more like a
15 to 20% boost versus the 4070 TI nons
super because the 4070 TI has really not
been available since the 40 TI super
came out and I guess you could say that
about the 470 TI super relative to the
570 TI as well well because Nvidia just
likes replacing cards rather than having
more than one in the same category on
the market at the same time also
contributing to the reviews being not as
terrible this time around is that
comparisons to the 40 series and older
Generations is not quite as
disappointing compared to the recent
reviews of the 5080 and 5090 and on the
plus side efficiency is actually looking
quite good too that has been a strong
point for NVIDIA for some time now with
typical draw for the 570 TI being below
300 watts resulting in some nice cool
running temperature performance per watt
is also a strong point as Gamers Nexus
pointed out particularly when compared
to amd's 7900 series gpus or reviews
have really struggled to address is how
things will look tomorrow though when
5070 TI gpus go up for sale we've been
pitched a $750 base MSRP but early
listings as previously mentioned are
already jumping that price up to $900 at
minimum with some already going for
$1,000 or more and the 5070 TI is just
not worth $11,000 even if MSI throws a
lucky figure into the box for the first
run of sales despite anticipating that
prices will be exorbitantly high though
given the extremely limited available of
the 5080 and 5090 at launch we're not
optimistic that the 5070 TI will
suddenly just have way more gpus in
stock versus the other cards and it's
very likely that there will only be a
handful of these $750 models that are
actually sold and for some of them like
New Egg might force you to buy a whole
combo in order to get the card that you
actually want and that of course is just
due to limited avail ability and the
high demand right now and in case I
didn't point it out there is no Founders
Edition for the 5070 TI I am
anticipating that most board Partners
like Asus gigabyte MSI and so on will
opt to drop their allocated 5070 TI dies
into OC models that sell for 20 30% or
more over the $750 MSRP which makes it
very hard to assess real world pricing
resulting in the double conclusion that
most reviews have used to sum up the 570
TI at MSRP it's not a horrible value and
again that's tent amount to a ringing
endorsement given the current GPU
climate even with updated retail pricing
it's still hanging out with the 4070
super and the 7800 XT which are both
among the best options for bank for the
buck in the mid-range for the past year
or so but when you ratchet that price up
to $900 or more the cost per frame jumps
by about a bck 50 and the 5070 TI joins
this group of extremely poor value cards
at closer to $12 per frame and remember
even this top group up here with the
4070 super and the 7800 XT isn't the
best in terms of value what we really
want from a new generation of gpus is a
significant increase in value versus
last gen not just cozying right up to it
and hoping things will be fine for
another couple years next up we're going
to take a look at a chart that I put
together showing the generational uplift
of 70 TI class cards since there isn't
always a 70 TI class card in each
generation I'm Sometimes using TI
Sometimes using super or in the case of
the 900 series I'm just using the base
970 so starting with that top row GTX
970 which had an MSRP of $330 wasn't
that nice the 970 was an exceptional
value even with the 3.5 gig vram Scandal
if you guys remember that along with the
cards MSRP and launch date we're going
back about 10 plus years I have the two
generations old card which would be a 70
class or 70 TI class if available we can
see that the 970 was 62% faster than the
670 have a comparison to to the last
generation 70 class card the GTX 770 in
this case and the 970 was 43% faster
than that card and then where applicable
I'll list the last gen TI or super card
the performance increased there and then
the last gen Flagship which was the 780
Ti in this case the 970 was about 3%
slower than that card but do note that
that's a 970 not a TI or a super next we
have the 1070 The 1070 TI launched for
$400 in November 2017 and note that the
ti or super cards will often launch uh
significantly later than the original
cards that launch in that generation
like the 1070 actually launched in 2016
and the 1070 TI didn't come around for
about a year after that still it was a
136% improvement over the two gen's old
770 a 66% improvement over the last gen
970 there was not a 970 TI super but
there was a 980 TI and the 1070 TI was
26% faster than that card imagine that
the 5070 TI was 26% faster than the 490
wouldn't that be cool that would almost
be like what Jensen promised the 5070
performance would be like at the CES
keynote but he was talking about
multiframe generation which was a bunch
of anyway that's clearly a high
water mark and Nvidia wised up after
that with the 20 series with the 2070
super which launched in July 2019 for
$500 and yes again this was about a year
after the original RTX 20 series
launched out with the nons Super Cards
still 2070 super was 122% faster than
the 970 52% faster than the 1070 34%
faster than the 1070 TI and right about
on par with the 1080 TI coming in at 1%
faster and you will note that the
pricing has been steadily increasing
next we have the RTX 30 series with the
3070 TI which launched in May 2021 for
$600 that increase in price was the main
complaint about the 3070 TI it was 94%
faster than the 1070 TI 64% faster than
the 2070 and 45% faster than the 2070
super while also maintaining a 12% lead
over the 2080 TI and that leads us to
the 40 series I have the RTX 470 TI and
the 47 70 TI super both listed here
though their launches were separated by
about a year they came in at the same
$800 price and since they were never
really both available widely at the same
time I decided to put them both on the
chart so we can see the differences
between the two the 4070 TI super
despite its redundant name did provide
us with more performance for the same
price just about a year later 125%
faster than the 2070 super 66% faster
than the 3070 and 55% faster than the
3070 TI while coming in just shy of the
390 TI at minus 3% and that brings us to
today's launch the RTX 570 TI and when
it did the 80 with the same formatted
chart it was pretty glaring how much of
a drop off in relative performance the
80 was offering versus prior 80 class
cards the 5070 TI doesn't look quite so
bad in this format in fact the
percentage increase versus two gen old
is 138% percentage increase versus last
gen is 55% that's pretty much in the
same range versus the previous
generations compared to the 4070 TI
super though we're only at 11% increase
and versus the 490 we're atus 28% and
that is also a disappointing result as
we can see in previous generations where
we were able to get pretty close with
the 70 TI class card sometimes
outperforming the last gen Flagship
sometimes being within 5 or 10% but
clearly not the generational uplift that
we have enjoyed in the past and as I
mentioned also in the video I posted
earlier today there are various reasons
why the pricing is so horrible but a big
reason is that these Blackwell gpus are
still built bu on tsmc's 4N process
which is why Nvidia had to stop
production of the 40 series cards in
order to switch over production to the
50 Series cards and they could have
mitigated this situation I think if they
had made some accommodations for
consumers out there simply by waiting
until more gpus were produced and more
stock was available or simply by
allowing more inventory overlap from the
40 series to the 50 Series but it seems
like what they were actually trying to
do was use up all that 40 series
inventory before the 50 Series launched
and now you have a situation where
there's no cards on the market and
scalpers are just having a field day for
all these reasons it's very difficult to
properly review the 570 TI right now and
we probably won't have a good
understanding until the dust clears and
we're at least a couple weeks out from
launch and we see how quickly restocks
are coming into play at retailers I
still very much believe that next
Generation gpus should significantly
improve performance per dollar Nvidia
really seems to not want to do that
lately the 5070 TI would at least be
reasonable or not awful if stock was
available and they could actually be
purchased for $750 but for now the 570
TI is basically just another RTX 480 or
480 super maybe 1 or 2% slower it's
going to sell for the same street price
around $1,000 with very similar
performance and uh what else is there to
say I guess uh we can hold out hope that
these 12v 2x6 connectors are less likely
to melt on a 5070 TI due to it being a
lower wattage card but uh man that's a
that's a pretty thin Silver Lining if
you ask me but that is my review recap
and a bit of a historical look at the
5070 TI class cards from Nvidia where we
can see that Gamers aren't really being
given a lot to be excited about with
this newest generation and I think a lot
of the blame lies with Nvidia I'd say
most of the blame but we can also blame
the retailers and addin board partners
for taking advantage of the pricing
situation as much as they can right now
as well but guys if you enjoyed this
video consider hitting the thumbs up
button and in the description down below
you can find links to all of the reviews
that I used to do this review Roundup
and you can also find a link to my store
at paul.net where you can buy some
merchandise to help support my channel
and get yourself some high quality
merchandise that's all for this one
thanks again we'll see you in the next
video